Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The epic return of Yellowstone is now streaming exclusively on Paramount+. You destroy me, you destroy yourself. Unlike you, I keep my promises. The wait is over. Yellowstone, new episodes now streaming exclusively on Paramount Plus.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。《黄石》史诗级回归，现正于 Paramount+ 独家热播。你毁了我，就是毁了你自己。跟你不同，我向来言出必行。等待已经结束。《黄石》全新剧集现正于 Paramount+ 独家热播。
Interior Chinatown is an all-new series based on the best-selling novel by Charles Yu about a struggling Asian actor who gets a bigger part than he expected when he witnesses a crime in Chinatown. Now streaming only on Disney+. Visit California.com. On the deck of the Victory, Jervis clenched his fists in frustration. The Spanish were getting away. After all the waiting, it had all been for nothing. And then, to his amazement, one of the smaller British ships did something extraordinary.
《唐人街内情》是一部全新的剧集，改编自游朝凯的同名畅销小说，讲述了一位苦苦挣扎的亚裔演员在唐人街目睹了一起犯罪后，意外得到了比预期更重的戏份。现正于 Disney+ 独家热播。访问 California.com。“胜利”号的甲板上，杰维斯气愤地紧握双拳。西班牙人逃掉了。经历了所有的等待，这一切竟然都白费了。紧接着，令他惊叹的是，其中一艘较小的英国军舰做出了一个非同寻常的举动。
In flagrant defiance of all his orders, it broke out of the line, abandoning the planned formation and striking out alone across the sea. The Admiral's jaw dropped. The unknown captain was heading straight for the Spanish fleet. He was bearing down on the gigantic enemy flagship, the Santísima Trinidad, guns blazing for death or glory. And then Jervis realized who it was. It was Nelson. So honestly, Dominic, do you know, my daughters now, I'm afraid, are too old to have a bedtime story read
无视了所有的命令，它公然冲出列阵，抛弃了原定的阵型，孤身一人向海面上冲去。海军上将惊得下巴都掉了下来。这个不知名的舰长正径直驶向西班牙舰队。他正朝着敌方那艘庞大的旗舰“三位一体”号逼近，炮火轰鸣，誓死求胜。然后，杰维斯认出了那是谁。是纳尔逊。所以老实说，多米尼克，你知道的，我女儿现在，恐怕已经大到不再需要别人
to them. Because actually Katie's 25. But I'm quite tempted to get it for them for Christmas and read it to them. Oh, you absolutely should. I can't think of a better way you could spend Christmas. So this is from Nelson Hero of the Seas, your thrilling new book aimed at a younger audience, but very much tailored for an adult patriot as well. Definitely. And this is heroic. I mean, astonishing moment will come to it in the Battle of Cape St. Vincent fought on
给她们读睡前故事了。因为其实凯蒂已经25岁了。但我还真挺想圣诞节买一本读给她们听的。哦，你绝对应该这么做。我想象不出比这更好的圣诞节度过方式了。所以这是出自《纳尔逊：海洋英雄》，这是你为年轻读者创作的全新惊险力作，不过也非常适合成年爱国者阅读。绝对是的。而且这非常英勇。我的意思是，在1797年
the 14th February 1797. And this is the feat that makes Nelson a national hero for the first time. And we'll be looking at that. We'll be looking at how he loses his arm. Yes. So today's episode, I mean, there's no disguising it. This is history as pure swashbuckling melodrama. Daring do. Absolutely. And we have no apology in saying that. So let's remind ourselves, Tom, where we got to. We are in February 1797.
2月14日爆发的圣文森特角战役中，会出现一个令人震惊的时刻。这就是让纳尔逊首次成为民族英雄的壮举。我们将会探讨这一点。我们也会探讨他是如何失去手臂的。是的。所以今天的节目，毋庸置疑，这就是一部纯粹的刀剑与斗篷式的情节剧。充满勇气的壮举。绝对是的。对此我们毫无保留。那么，汤姆，让我们回顾一下我们进展到了哪里。我们现在是在1797年2月。
The British have been driven out of the Mediterranean by Napoleon's advances on land. The Spanish have joined the war and are looking to link up with the French, which would be disastrous for Britain. Nelson has been heading back through the Mediterranean. He's gone through the Straits of Gibraltar. He has sailed through the Spanish. He's gone through the Straits of Gibraltar. He has sailed
英国人在拿破仑陆上攻势的逼迫下被逐出了地中海。西班牙已经参战，并正寻求与法国会师，这对英国来说将是灾难性的。纳尔逊一直在经由地中海撤回。他已经穿过了直布罗陀海峡。他已经穿过了西班牙。他已经穿过了直布罗陀海峡。他已经
through the Spanish fleet in the fog and to his relief he is linked up with Sir John Jervis, old oak, this toad-like indomitable Admiral off Capes and Vincent. And now Jervis has the chance to draw up his plans and to strike for victory. And the scene is set for what the British hope will be a decisive clash, because even though the British are outnumbered, their hope is that by engaging the Spanish, they can capture ships, they can maim ships, they can impair it. And the reason why this really matters is that Jervis, of course, he's down off the coast of Spain and Portugal, but his main thoughts are surely focused on the channel. Because the risk is that if the Spanish fleet is able to continue on its way northwards
在浓雾中穿过了西班牙舰队，令他感到宽慰的是，他在圣文森特角外海与约翰·杰维斯爵士——这位老橡树、这位长相如蟾蜍般不屈不挠的海军上将——会合了。现在，杰维斯有机会制定他的计划并为胜利发起进攻。英国人所希望的一场决定性冲突的舞台已经搭好了，因为尽管英国人寡不敌众，但他们希望通过与西班牙人交战，他们可以俘获战舰，他们可以重创战舰，他们可以削弱战舰。而这之所以真正重要，是因为杰维斯当然身处西班牙和葡萄牙海岸外，但他的主要心思无疑都集中在海峡上。因为风险在于，如果西班牙舰队能够继续其向北前往
to Brest in France and to join up with the French fleet. Yep. Then even though the Royal Navy is the largest fleet in the world, the combination of the second largest, the French and the third largest, the Spanish, I mean, potentially it could threaten Britain with the loss of the control of the channel and that would open up a possibility of a French invasion. Exactly. So Jervis knows, as you said, that he is outnumbered, but he believes they have to take on the Spanish now to stop them linking up.
法国布雷斯特并与法国舰队会合的行程。没错。那么，即便皇家海军是世界上最大的舰队，第二大的法国舰队与第三大的西班牙舰队的联合，我的意思是，潜在地可能会威胁到英国对海峡控制权的丧失，而那将开启法国入侵的可能性。没错。所以杰维斯知道，正如你所说，他寡不敌众，但他相信他们现在必须迎战西班牙人，以阻止他们会合。
And he is confident, as he later put it, in the skill, valor and discipline of the officers and men I had the happiness to command. And that is not just patriotic boosterism. That is a genuine, realistic appreciation of the Royal Navy's qualities as opposed to those of the Royal Navy's qualities as opposed to those of the Spanish Navy. And perhaps specifically of the fighting quality of the captains that he has promoted and favoured. And one of the things I think that Jervis has instilled in his captains is that, you know, there is the letter of an order and there is the spirit of an order.
正如他后来所说的那样，他对自己“有幸指挥的军官和士兵的技能、勇气和纪律”充满信心。这不仅仅是爱国主义的盲目吹嘘。这是对皇家海军品质的一种真诚、现实的赞赏，相比之下，皇家海军的品质与西班牙海军的品质形成了对比，或许也特别赞赏了他所提拔和青睐的那些舰长的战斗品质。而我认为杰维斯灌输给他的舰长的其中一件事就是，你知道的，命令有条文规定，也有命令的精神所在。
Yes, that's right. And he's trying to encourage his captains to show initiative if the opportunity should arrive. Which is exactly what Nelson will do later on. So Nelson gets that, I think, from Jervis. So that day when Nelson arrives, Jervis moves him to another ship, a bigger ship, the captain, 74 guns. He's very pleased to find that the captain
是的，没错。他正试图鼓励他的舰长们，如果机会来临，要展现出主动性。这正是纳尔逊后来要做的事。所以我想纳尔逊是从杰维斯那里学到了这一点。因此，在纳尔逊抵达的那天，杰维斯把他调到了另一艘更大的船上，也就是拥有74门火炮的“卡佩坦”号。他非常高兴地发现这艘船
is in great condition. The crew have been drilling and drilling with the guns all the time, preparing for this opportunity. That night Jervis makes his ships keep close order. They can hear the Spanish guns, the signal guns, away in the fog. Then dawn comes. It's the 14th of February 1797. It's a cold cold misty morning. The lead ship, which is Culloden under Thomas
状态极佳。船员们一直在不断地用火炮进行演练，为这个机会做准备。那天晚上，杰维斯让他的船只保持紧密队形。他们能在浓雾中听到西班牙人的炮声，也就是信号枪声。接着黎明到来。那是1797年2月14日。这是一个寒冷、寒冷、多雾的早晨。领头船是托马斯·特鲁布里奇
Trubridge, Nelson's friend from episode one. And he's a man who loves glory, doesn't he? He absolutely does. They said nobody in the fleet. His Jervis's favourite, Thomas Trubridge, everybody knows. Because he's really, I mean, he's risen from nothing. He was an equal seaman. He's properly meritocratic. And they always used to say, nobody hates the French more than Thomas Truebridge. He really does burn with zeal for king and country. So his lookouts have spotted ships and the British start to advance very slowly, deliberately.
指挥的“卡洛登”号，他是纳尔逊在第一集里的朋友。他是一个热爱荣誉的人，对不对？他绝对是的。他们说舰队里没有人……他是杰维斯的最爱，托马斯·特鲁布里奇，人尽皆知。因为他真的，我的意思是，他是白手起家。他曾是一名普通水手。他完全是精英统治论的产物。人们过去常说，没有人比托马斯·特鲁布里奇更恨法国人。他确实对国王和国家燃烧着狂热的激情。所以他的瞭望员发现了船只，英国人开始非常缓慢、审慎地前进。
People who remember Atrophalga series will remember that you don't often charge into these battles. You proceed in a very stately kind of considered way. It's like a kind of dance, isn't it? You line up opposite each other. That's the convention. And there is a wonderful, wonderful story told of this. So the captain of the victory is looking through the telescope. Jervis is on the victory, but of course he's not the captain of that ship because he's the commandering the entire fleet. And the captain says, there are eight sail of the line, Sir John. Very well, sir.
经历过“特拉法加”系列节目的听众会记得，你通常不会直接冲进这些战斗中。你会以一种非常庄严、深思熟虑的方式推进。这就像某种舞蹈，对吧？你们在彼此对面排成一列。这就是惯例。关于这一点，有一个非常精彩、精彩的故事。因此，“胜利”号的舰长正通过望远镜观察。杰维斯在“胜利”号上，但当然他不是那艘船的舰长，因为他是整支舰队的指挥官。舰长说：“约翰爵士，有八艘队列舰。”“很好，长官。”
There are 20 sail of the line, Sir John. Very well, sir. There are 25 sail of the line, Sir John. Very well, sir. There are 27 sail of the line, Sir John. And so at this point, the captain of the victory is clearly thinking there are far too many of them, you know. Let's get out of here.
“约翰爵士，有二十艘队列舰。”“很好，长官。”“约翰爵士，有二十五艘队列舰。”“很好，长官。”“约翰爵士，有二十七艘队列舰。”所以在这个时候，“胜利”号的舰长显然在想，对方数量实在太多了，你知道的。我们离开这里吧。
And Jervis just says, enough, sir. No more of that. The die is cast. And even if there are 50 sale, I will go through them. That is the Sandbrook spirit. And behind them, there's a Canadian officer, I think he is, who hears this and he can't restrain himself and he shouts out, that's right, Sir John. And by God, we'll give them a damn good licking.
而杰维斯只是说：“够了，长官。不要再说了。木已成舟。哪怕有五十艘船，我也要冲过去。”这就是桑德布鲁克精神。在他们身后，我想有一位加拿大军官听到了这话，他情不自禁地大喊：“说得对，约翰爵士！看在上帝的份上，我们要狠狠地教训他们一顿！”
Love it. This is how we talk about rival history podcasts, isn't it, Tom? It is. Yes, Sir John. And by God, we'll give them a damn good licking. Love it. This is how we talk about rival history podcasts, isn't it Tom? It is. Yes, it is. So, Jervis has 15 ships of the line. The Spanish have 27 ships. The Spanish have more three deck of ships. The three deck of ships the Spanish have have 112 guns each. And they also have a ship called the Santissima Trinidad. And that's an absolute monster, isn't it? Four decks, 130 guns, the most formidable warship on earth, arguably that's ever been
太棒了。这就是我们谈论竞争历史播客的方式，对吧，汤姆？正是如此。是的，约翰爵士。看在上帝的份上，我们要狠狠地教训他们一顿！太棒了。这就是我们谈论竞争历史播客的方式，对吧，汤姆？正是如此。是的，确实如此。所以，杰维斯拥有15艘队列舰。西班牙人有27艘船。西班牙人拥有更多三层甲板战舰。西班牙人拥有的三层甲板战舰每艘都有112门火炮。他们还有一艘名为“三位一体”号的船。那绝对是一个怪物，对吧？四层甲板，130门火炮，可以说是地球上有史以来建造的最令人生畏的军舰。
built. Yeah. So there's another officer in the British line who looks at them and says in a tone of huge excitement, by my soul, they are thumpers. This is probably the story in all history that shows Britain at its best. I think it's fair to say, Tom. Yeah. If only every episode could be like this. The two fleets are converging. Jervis is completely calm. He instills this sense of tranquillity and confidence in his captains. And Dominic, just to reiterate, the key thing here is the British fleet is outnumbered,
是的。所以英国战线上的另一位官兵看着它们，以一种极其兴奋的语气说道：“凭我的灵魂，这些都是庞然大物。”可以说，这大概是整部历史中最能展现英国最好一面的故事了，汤姆，我想这么说并不过分。是的。要是每一集都能这样就好了。两支舰队正在汇合。杰维斯完全保持着镇定。他在他的舰长们中间灌输了这种宁静和自信的感觉。多米尼克，再次重申，这里的关键点是，英国舰队寡不敌众，
but they're still expecting to win. Completely. And they will win by engaging the Spanish. So they have to engage the Spanish. Yes. They're worried that the Spanish fleet will kind of sail back, will go to Cadiz or whatever. Yes, exactly. So even though they're outnumbered, it's the Spanish who are probably going to try and get away.
但他们仍然期待着胜利。完全如此。而且他们将通过与西班牙人交战来取得胜利。所以他们必须与西班牙人交战。是的。他们担心西班牙舰队会掉头返航，会去加的斯或其他地方。是的，完全如此。所以即使他们寡不敌众，也可能是西班牙人试图逃跑。
Exactly. Because the Spanish, I mean, what we're saying about the British capabilities, this is not us being... Jingoistic. ...sort of silly and jingoistic. The Spanish and the French absolutely know this and they factor this in. You know, when you're up against a British fleet, you're in trouble and the best thing to do is to try to get away. And it's not just the gunnery, it's also that they've just been out all the time because of their limes. Yeah. But the Spanish and the French can't do that. They have to spend most of their time in port. Yes, exactly. The British are experienced, they are drilled, they are formidable. And I think actually running through this whole Nelson story, as much as we praise
没错。因为西班牙人，我的意思是，我们关于英国作战能力的说法，这并不是我们在……盲目自大。……表现得愚蠢而沙文主义。西班牙人和法国人和绝对清楚这一点，并且把这一点考虑在内。你知道的，当你与英国舰队对抗时，你就麻烦了，最好的做法就是设法逃跑。而且不仅是火炮技术，还因为他们由于食用青柠，随时都在海上待命。是的。但西班牙人和法国人做不到这一点。他们大部分时间都必须待在港口里。是的，完全如此。英国人经验丰富，训练有素，实力雄厚。而且我认为，贯穿整个纳尔逊的故事，尽管我们赞美
Nelson's individual genius, there is a sense that when a British fleet and a Spanish or French fleet go into battle, the general expectation is that the British will always win. Don't you think? I do. And I think it's because chiefly thanks to the process of industrialization and globalization that the Royal Navy is both facilitating and being sharpened and honed by Britain has a weapon of lethal destructiveness rather in the way that with the longbows and the
纳尔逊个人的天才，但有一种感觉是，当英国舰队与西班牙或法国舰队投入战斗时，普遍的期望是英国人总是会赢。你不这么认为吗？我确实这么认为。而且我认为这主要归功于皇家海军既在推动、同时又被英国推动的工业化和全球化进程所打磨和锤炼，使其成为一件具有致命破坏力的武器，就像在百年战争中，通过短暂使用长弓以及长弓手和全副武装的士兵，他们能够在基督教世界中最强大的力量面前树立自己的威望。这真的是英国拥有某种尖端进攻性武器的唯一另一个时期，而法国人和西班牙人对此既尊重又确实感到恐惧。为了勾勒出这场战役的整体画面，西班牙船只分为两个梯队。他们首先有18艘船，然后是9艘，并且它们的阵型非常凌乱。所以杰维斯能看出他们状态不佳。英国人则在以一种冷静、稳定、受控的方式推进，此时正悬挂着英国国旗。那里的计划实际上是
use of longbowmen and men at arms in the Hundred Years War for a brief time, they were able to impose themselves on the greatest power in Christendom. This is really the only other period where Britain has a kind of cutting edge offensive weapon and the French and the Spanish respect that and indeed fear it. So to give a sense of the battle picture, the Spanish ships are in two divisions. They have an 18 ships first and then nine, and they're in very ragged formation. So Jervis can tell they're not quite at it. The British, they are advancing sort of in a calm, steady, controlled way, now flying the colors of the Union Jack. And the plan there is that effectively
他们将向西班牙舰队推进，然后他们将进行变向，这意味着顶风呈之字形向较大的西班牙分队航行，并将西班牙舰队一分为二。他们将对付西班牙第一支较大的分队，然后回过头来对付第二支分队。当然，这并不是西班牙人所期望的正式战斗之舞。这也证明了这一点，我想这实际上是对仅在一条线上作战的局限性的一种不耐烦，你知道的，一对一的作战，不仅仅是纳尔逊一个人这样，而是整个皇家海军的军官阶层都开始掌握这一点。我的意思，霍瑟姆没有，但杰维斯显然做到了。绝对是的，是的，他做到了。所以引领战线的是托马斯·
they will advance on the Spanish fleet and then they will tack, which means kind of zigzagging upwind towards the larger Spanish division and they will cut the Spanish in two. They will deal with the first larger division of the Spanish, then they will turn back to deal with the second division. And of course, this is not the formal dance of battle that the Spanish would expect. And it bears witness to the fact that this, I suppose really an impatience with the limitations of fighting simply in a line, you know, one against the other, that it's not just Nelson, that this is something that the entire officer class of the Royal Navy is starting to get to grips with. I mean, Hotham hadn't, but Jervis clearly has. Absolutely, yes, yes, he has. So leading the line is Thomas
特鲁布里奇的“卡洛登”号。“胜利”号在中央，实际上纳尔逊的舰长（船）在后方。最尾端是他的朋友库思伯特·科林伍德的船。太棒了。他们继续前进。11点30分，“卡洛登”号抵达敌方战线。就在这时，杰维斯发出信号，说现在是顶风作之字形航行并将西班牙舰队一分为二的时候了。硝烟已经开始弥漫，西班牙人开始开火了。杰维斯一直在四分仪甲板上，现在他走上了船尾楼甲板，以便更好地观察战况。他的船几乎被烟雾笼罩。
Trubage's Culloden. Victory is in the centre and actually Nelson's captain is towards the back. At the very back is his friend Cuthbert Collingwood's ship. Excellent. On they go. At 11.30, Culloden reaches the enemy line. At this point, Jervis sends the signal saying now is the time to zigzag upwind and to cut the Spanish fleet in two. And already the kind of gun smoke is starting to, the Spanish are starting to fire. And Jervis has been on the quarter deck and now he goes up onto the poop deck to get a better sense of the action. His ship is kind of wreathed in smoke.
正当他站在那里时，一名军官甚至无法躲闪，任凭子弹或大炮轰鸣。正当他站在那里时，一颗炮弹猛烈击中了旁边一名军官的头部。杰维斯的身上溅满了鲜血、脑浆和头骨碎片。他非常冷静地擦掉脸上的血迹，放下望远镜，大步走回四分仪甲板。太棒了。太精彩了。我在船上时就是这样表现的，汤姆。
And while he's standing there, an officer can't duck, even as bullets are firing or cannon or whatever. And as he's standing there, a cannonball smacks into the head of an officer next to him. Jervis is absolutely spattered by blood, brains, fragments of skull. He wipes the gore from his face very coolly and lowers his telescope and stumps back to the quarter deck. Love it. Brilliant. That's exactly how I behave on a ship, Tom.
你完全说得对。大约在这个时候，随着炮火开始，杰维斯意识到他的计划出了大问题。基本上，那些正在成功的船只，第二批英国船只在混战、混乱和烟雾中错过了他的最后信号。所以他们没有变向。他们没有变向，也没有掉头去对付第一分队。而在不深入探讨海军战术细节的情况下，这意味着
You're quite right. About this point, as the firing starts, Jervis realises that something has gone very badly wrong with his plan. That basically the ships that are succeeding, the second lot of British ships have missed his last signal in the confusion, in the chaos, in the smoke. So they're not tacking. And they are not tacking, they are not turning to deal with the First Division. And without getting massively into kind of the minutiae naval tactics, what this means
他们掉头需要时间。在这段时间里，较小的西班牙船只将会逃脱。它们将能够逃往它们本土的港口避难，也就是加的斯。另一方面，较大的西班牙分队大概也能成功逃脱，他们将能够绕行并与战友会合。就在那时，他看到一艘英国军舰违抗命令，孤身出发，打破了进攻队形，直奔敌方旗舰“三位一体”号而去。那是谁？是纳尔逊。是纳尔逊。是纳尔逊在
is it will take time for them to turn. In that time, the smaller Spanish ships will get away. They will be able to run to the sanctuary of their home port, which is Quediz. And on the other hand, the larger Spanish division will probably also manage to get away, they will be able to loop around and rejoin their comrades. And it's at that point that he sees one British ship, disobeying his orders, striking off alone, breaking the attack formation and heading straight for the enemy flagship that's Santissima Trinidad. And who is it? It is Nelson. It's Nelson. It's Nelson on
“卡佩坦”号上。所以纳尔逊一直在“卡佩坦”号上观察着这一切。他知道自己受到了严格的指示：不要放弃进攻队形，保持队形。但一看到情况不对，纳尔逊就想，我要无视条文的字面意思，顺应条文的精神。我要顺应精神。你知道的，情况不对了。我要自己做主。我要直奔地球上最大的船——“三位一体”号。但为了强调纳尔逊这样做的胆识，不仅是他孤身一人在向这艘巨大的船冲锋，还有整个海军的体制是建立在服从的基础上的，尤其是在
the captain. So Nelson has been watching all this on the captain. He knows that he's under strict instructions. Do not abandon the attack formation. Stay in formation. But as soon as he sees that something is going wrong, Nelson thinks I will ignore the letter of the law. I'll go with the spirit of the law. I will go with the spirit. You know, it's gone wrong. I'll take it into my own hands. I'm going to go straight for the biggest ship on earth, the Santis Madrinida. But just to emphasize the balls of Nelson in doing this, it's not just that he is charging alone, you know, this vast ship. It's also the fact that the entire structure of the Navy is founded on obedience and particularly in
战斗中公然违抗指令。你知道的，这违背了一个依靠严格纪律才能生存的服务机构的每一项本能。如果一切都搞砸了，如果西班牙舰队还是逃掉了，或者更糟糕的是，如果英国人开始损失船只，那么纳尔逊就会成为替罪羊。他会被毁掉的。是的。哦，我的意思是，他可能会被送上军事法庭。绝对是的。但这场赌博改变了战局。
battle to flout instructions. You know, it goes against every instinct of a service that depends on strict discipline for its very survival. And if it all goes wrong, if the Spanish fleet still gets away, or even more, if the British start losing ships, then Nelson will be the scapegoat. He will be ruined. Yeah. Oh, I mean, he could be called marshals. Absolutely. But that gamble changes the course of the battle.
这展现了难以置信的勇气。他在向这艘庞大的船只开火。西班牙人在还击。敌人的炮弹撕裂了他的风帆和索具。其他西班牙船只开始向他汇聚。但他这样做的举动意味着他们没能逃脱，因为他们掉头去与他作战。关键在于，这展现了难以置信的勇气，而且也非常有效。
It shows incredible courage. He is firing on this enormous ship. The Spanish are firing. There's enemy shot ripping into his sails and his rigging. Other Spanish ships begin to converge on him. But the fact that he does that means they don't get away because they turn to fight him. The thing is it shows incredible courage, but also it's very effective.
通过直奔这艘巨大的西班牙船，他为其他英国船只赢得了改变航向并跟随他的时间。而且他还阻止了西班牙人分头逃跑，因为他们没有冲向加的斯，而是掉头来应对纳尔逊。因此，在片刻之间，是的，他与这艘西班牙船展开了一场激烈的交火，但英国船只现在正赶来支援他，特鲁布里奇和“卡洛登”号，科林伍德和那艘优秀的——所以所有的伙计们都在。
By going straight to this huge Spanish ship, he has bought time for the other ships, British ships to change course and to follow him. But also he stopped the Spanish from breaking away because instead of rushing for Cadiz, they've turned to deal with Nelson. So within moments, yeah, he's engaged in this colossal kind of firefight with the Spanish ship, but British ships are now coming to his aid, Troubridge and Culloden, Collingwood in the excellent- So all the lads.
所有的老朋友都在。是的，所有的老朋友都在。是的，所有的老朋友都在。“卡佩坦”号受到了可怕的损害。它的主桅杆布满了弹孔，另一根桅杆被炸飞落入海中。船舵被撞成碎片，风帆被撕成了碎片。是的，而碎片真的很危险，对吧？所以不仅仅是炮弹，还有炮弹击中木头时飞溅出来的木片。而在此时，纳尔逊的腹侧被一块巨大的木片击中了。所以这是又一次，虽然不如刺伤他眼睛导致该眼失明的伤口那样明显严重，但它确实——我的意思是，这给他余生带来了麻烦。
All his pals. Yeah, all his pals. Yeah, all his pals. The captain is taking horrendous damage. So it's main mast is riddled with holes, other mast is blasted overboard. The wheel is splintered, the sails are shredded. Yeah, and splinters are really dangerous, aren't they? So it's not just the cannonballs, it's when the cannonball smacks into wood and the splinters go out. And at this point, Nelson is hit by a massive splinter in the side of his stomach. So this is another, it's not as kind of obviously bad as the wound to his eye, which blinds him in that eye, but it is, I mean, it causes him trouble for the rest of his life.
这是一处非常严重的伤情。是的，绝对是的。确实如此。他知道他的船撑不了多久了，他们正遭到西班牙人猛烈的轰炸。他对船长说，好了，够了，直接朝最近的西班牙船冲过去，那就是“圣尼古拉”号。直接冲过去，撞上去，我们干吧。船长（转动舵轮，转动剩下的残破舵轮），他们径直朝着西班牙船驶去，并撞上了“圣尼古拉”号。我们刚刚提到纳尔逊的腹部卡着一块巨大的灰色木片。这能阻止他吗？
It's a very serious wound. Yeah, absolutely. It does. He knows his ship can't take it much longer, that they're being absolutely pummeled by the Spanish. And he says to the master of his ship, okay, enough, go straight for the nearest Spanish ship, which is the San Nicolás. Just go straight for it, ram into it, let's do this. The master, you know, turns the wheel, what's left of the wheel, they head straight for the Spanish ship and they crash into the San Nicolas. So we've just mentioned Nelson has got a massive grey splinter stuck in his stomach. Does it
这会让他退缩吗？绝对没有。一点也没有。此时他已经下达了命令：来吧，我们要这么做，我们要登船。他的船员们已经武装起来了。他们有长矛，有手枪，有些人有短弯刀，有战斧，有些人甚至拿了屠夫刀，他们手里能拿到什么就拿什么。他跳上了——我的意思是，这是，你知道的，任何编剧都编不出这样的情节。他跳到了一根悬在“圣尼古拉”号上方的横梁上，拔出佩剑，大声喊出了
stop him? Does it put him off? Absolutely not. No, not at all. By this point he's given orders, come on, we're going to do this, we're going to board. His crew have armed themselves. They've got pikes, they've got pistols, some of them have got cutlasses, they've got tomahawks, some of them kind of butchers knives, they've got everything they can get their hands on. He jumps onto, I mean, this is, you know, no script writer would invent this. He jumps onto this beam that overhangs the San Nicolas, he draws his sword and he literally
“不成功便成仁”。然后他跳上了“圣尼古拉”号。我的意思是，这就像，为什么罗素·克劳没有扮演纳尔逊？我的意思是，我想他曾演过杰克·奥布里，但这对某人来说是一个绝佳的角色，不是吗？他跳上了西班牙船。当他到达那里时，他发现西班牙船“圣尼古拉”号上已经到处都是尸体。他的炮手们干得非常漂亮。然后是他带着手下穿过船舱的场景，所有的海军陆战队员及其他人都在他身后。火枪弹向他们射来，他的海军陆战队员，他退后一步，他的海军陆战队员
shouts death or glory. And then he jumps onto the San Nicolas. I mean, this is like, why didn't Russell Crowe play Nelson? I mean, I suppose he was Captain Jack Albury, but this is a brilliant part for somebody, isn't it? He jumps onto the Spanish ship. When he gets there, he finds the Spanish ship, the San Nicolás, is already littered with bodies. His gunners have done their work very well. And then there's the scene of him charging through the cabins with his men behind him, all his Marines and whatnot. Musket shots come at them, his Marines, he steps back and his Marines
开始行动。他们继续前进，一路在船上战斗。他们来到了布满西班牙人尸体的船尾楼甲板，西班牙人扔下了武器。此时，他已经俘获了这艘船。你知道的，他觉得太棒了。仅此一项就是一项了不起的壮举，对吧？300年来，还没有哪个英国军官登船并俘获敌舰。这太罕见了。然后，正当他喘着粗气时，更多戏剧性的转折出现了，火枪弹开始如雨点般打在甲板上，他抬起头，意识到在混乱中，“圣尼古拉”号与另一艘西班牙船纠缠在了一起，那是一艘名为
sort of do their work. They keep going, fighting their way through the ship. They get to the quarter deck littered with Spanish bodies and the Spanish throw down their weapons. And at this point, he's captured the ship. You know, he thinks brilliant. This alone is an incredible feat, right? No British officer has boarded and captured an enemy ship for 300 years. It's so rare. And then just as he's kind of panting, more drama, another twist, musket balls start peppering the deck and he looks up and he realizes that in the chaos, the San Nicolás has become entangled with another Spanish ship, a three-decker ship called
“圣何塞”号的三层甲板战舰。所以这是一艘巨大、庞大、隐现于他们上方的庞然大物。“圣何塞”号的人站在他们的桅盘上，向“圣尼古拉”号上的纳尔逊和他的手下开火。这可以说是最精彩的时刻，不是吗？因为纳尔逊对此的反应不是想着，哦，我们最好撤退。而是去登那艘船。
the San Jose. So this is enormous, hulking, looming over them. And the San Jose men are up on their kind of nests, firing down on Nelson and his men on the San Nicolás. And this is the greatest moment, isn't it? Because Nelson's response to this rather than thinking, Oh, we better be to retreat. It's to board that ship.
这太不可思议了。别忘了他的单眼失明了。他的肋部还卡着一块木片。他跑向船舷。他跨过缝隙跃上了“圣何塞”号。双手抓着船侧往上爬。非常像好莱坞大片。差点掉下去。身后的人们也在做同样的事。他们蜂拥登上“圣何塞”号，双手抓着船侧往上爬，差点掉下去。
This is incredible. Don't forget he is blind in one eye. He's got a splinter in his side. He runs to the side. He leaps across the gap to the San Jose. Kind of holds himself up the side. Very Hollywood. Almost falls. There's men doing the same behind him. They swarm aboard the San Jose, kind of holds himself up the side, almost falls.
身後的人們也在做同樣的事。他們蜂擁登上「聖何塞」號。西班牙人對此大感意外，許多人立刻扔下了武器。這艘船的艦長仍在向「聖何塞」號開火。西班牙人幾乎立刻就放棄了抵抗。這簡直是一個令人難以置信的場景。我的意思是，關於這件事，它非常符合納爾遜的風格。
There's men doing the same behind him. They swarm aboard the San Jose. The Spanish are so taken aback by this, there's a lot of them throw down their weapons straight away. This captain is still firing at the San Jose. The Spanish give up pretty much straight away. And it's just an unbelievable scene. I mean, the thing about it is, it's very Nelson.
這純粹是榮耀。我的意思是，這是男孩自己的冒險。如果你在電影裏看到它，你都不會相信。我的意思是，它是如此非凡，以至於帕特里克·奧布里安甚至在傑克·奧布里最戲劇化的時刻，也從未敢想出如此不可信的事情。所以納爾遜贏得了這份不可思議的榮耀，但他做到這一點的方式是在不僅一艘、而是兩艘西班牙船上造成了慘絕人寰的屠殺。有目擊者見證了英國人下到船艙底層時所看到的景象。在兩艘船上，他們都見證了甲板上發生的恐怖景象，但走到船艙底層，
It's pure glory. I mean, it's boy's own. You wouldn't believe it if you saw it in a film. I mean, it's so extraordinary that Patrick O'Brien never dared, even at Jack Albury's most dramatic, to come up with something so improbable. So Nelson has won this incredible glory, but he's done it by inflicting utter carnage on not one, but two Spanish ships. There's an eyewitness to what the British find when they go below decks. So of both the ships, they've seen the horror of what's happened on the decks, but going down below decks,
這正是英國火炮發揮威力的地方。這些甲板上全是屍體，有些人的頭被炸飛，有些人的雙腿和雙臂斷裂，其餘的人都被炸得粉碎，內臟散落一地，鮮血流淌得如此濃稠。我們走在甲板上，鞋子簡直要浸泡在人類的鮮血中，這是一個悲慘的景象，太令人震撼而無法言說，但他剛剛說過了。我也剛剛說過了。正是榮耀與屠殺的結合，我認為，使得納爾遜的成就既令人激動，又令人毛骨悚然。
this is where British artillery has had its impact. These decks were full of dead bodies, some with their heads and others both their legs and arms off and the rest knocked all to pieces and their entrails all about and blood running so thick. We could not walk the decks in part without going over our shoes in human blood, which was a deplorable site and too shocking to relate, but he's just related it. And I've just related it as well. It's the combination of glory and carnage, I think, that makes Nelson's achievements simultaneously kind of thrilling, but also terrifying.
還有騎士精神，因為在西班牙人全部列隊站好之後，他沿著隊伍走去，與他們握手並收繳他們的劍。他們每個人都交出了自己的劍，而他則把劍交給他的手下，手下把劍夾在手臂下。他的手下——這非常像《怒海爭鋒》的風格——他的手下身上沾滿了煤灰、汙垢和鮮血，他們都簇擁在納爾遜周圍，其中一人拍了拍他的背，這是一種很好的冒犯君威的舉動，你知道的，這個家夥，這種類型，你可以想象這個粗獷的水手或者其他什麽人。他對他的同伴說，不是每天都能祝賀你的艦長俘獲了一艘西班牙軍艦的。
And gallantry, because after the Spanish all line up, he walks along the line, shaking their hands and taking their swords. They each handed their swords and he gives them to his men who put them under their arms. His men, it's very kind of master and commander. His men are covered with soot and grime and blood and they all crowd around Nelson and one of them slaps him on the back, which is great kind of Liz Majesty, you know, and this guy, this sort of, you can imagine this kind of burly sailor or whatever. He says to his mates, well, it's not every day you can congratulate your captain for capturing a Spanish man of war.
當然不是每天都有。好吧，因為古羅馬人有一種說法，如果一軍統帥殺死了敵方軍隊的統帥，這是一件非同尋常的事情，在整個羅馬歷史上隻發生過兩三次。我的意思是，這就是英國的對照物。他所做的事情是如此非凡。俘獲一艘船就能讓他成為民族英雄。俘獲兩艘呢？
And of course it isn't. Well, because the Romans had this thing that a commander of an army, if he killed the opposing commander of an army, this was an exceptional thing that only happened two or three times over the entire course of Roman history. I mean, this is the British parallel. It's so extraordinary what he's done. Capturing one ship would make him a national hero. Capturing two.
而且附帶條件是基本上為英國贏得了這場戰役。因為聖文森特角戰役是英國海軍精神的一場壓倒性勝利。15艘船擊敗了27艘，並且他們將其中的4艘作為戰利品俘獲了。數百名西班牙人陣亡，數千人受傷，3000人被俘。這是一個驚人的成就，每個人都知道，盡管傑維斯當然會攬去很大一部分功勞，但傑維斯自己心裡也清楚，納爾遜才是真正的今日之星。這場勝利還拯救了英國免受潛在的入侵。
And also to boot basically winning the battle for the British. Because Cape St Vincent is a crushing victory for British naval spirit. 15 ships have beaten 27 and they've captured four of the 27 as prizes. Hundreds of Spanish have been killed, thousands wounded, 3000 taken prisoner. It is an astounding achievement and everybody knows that much as of course Jervis would take a lot of the credits, Jervis himself knows it's Nelson who is the star of the day really. And this is a victory that has saved Britain from potential invasion to boot.
因此，英國民眾一方面可以大大鬆一口氣，另一方面又在報紙上讀到關於勇敢壯舉的不可思議的故事。納爾遜首次成為了一名民族英雄。老實說，這一直是納爾遜夢寐以求的。他一直想成為英雄。他一直想被人們仰慕。他一直想沐浴在榮耀之中。現在他做到了。我在第一集開頭談到過納爾遜的英雄主義中幾乎有一種阿喀流斯的特質。我們有科西嘉前總督的記錄和看法，他當時正隨艦隊在一艘護衛艦上觀看戰鬥。他將納爾遜描述為“超越荷馬或任何其他可能虛構的英雄”。
So the fact that people in Britain can kind of breathe a huge sigh of relief while also reading their newspapers about unbelievable tales of daring do. Nelson for the first time is a national hero. And to be honest, this is what Nelson has always dreamed of. He's always wanted to be a hero. He's always wanted to be admired. He's always want to be wreathed in glory. And now he is. I talked in the beginning of the first episode about how there's a kind of almost a quality of Achilles about Nelson's heroism. And we have the record, the opinion of the former viceroy of Corsica, who was with the fleet on one of the frigates and watching the action. And he described Nelson as a hero beyond Homer's or any other possible inventions.
哦，那真好。於是他們收到了家鄉的信件。傑維斯被封為聖文森特伯爵。納爾遜晉升為藍色艦隊少將兼巴斯勳章騎士。他收到了一封來自他父親的可愛信件，他父親當時正和範妮住在巴斯，他們經常在那裡泡溫泉。他父親說，他們那天早上去了音樂會。當人們看到他們時，向範妮鞠躬，就好像她自己贏得了這場戰役一樣，
Oh, that's nice. So they get letters from home. Jervis has been made the Earl of St Vincent. Nelson has been promoted to real Admiral of the Blue and Knight of the Order of the Bath. And he gets a lovely letter from his father who's staying with Fanny in Bath, where they would often take the waters. And his father said, they went to a concert that morning. And when people saw them, they bowed to Fanny as if she'd won the battle herself,
這對範妮來說一定很美好。然後納爾遜牧師說，當他們走回家時，陌生人走過來和他握手，他不得不走到一邊去，因為他太不好意思在公眾麵前因為自豪而哭泣了。這不是很美好嗎，湯姆？確實很美好。好吧，還要記住，你知道的，他們已經好幾年沒見到納爾遜了，而他一直忙著給範妮寫信說，哦，我可能會死。所以她內心的如釋重負一定是巨大的。所以，多米尼克，對納爾遜來說，這真的是他一直想要的一切，
which must be lovely for Fanny. And then the Reverend Nelson says that when they walked home, strangers came up to shake him by the hand and he had to step aside because he was so embarrassed to weep in public with pride. Isn't that nice, Tom? It is nice. Well, bear in mind also that, you know, they haven't seen Nelson for years and he's been busy writing back to Fanny saying, oh, I'd probably die. So her sense of relief must be enormous. So Dominic, really for Nelson, I mean, this is everything that he ever wanted
對他來說，這應該是超越的幸福時刻，是完全的巔峰時刻，但其中也有隱患，不是嗎？納爾遜的事情總是這樣，因為正如我們在第一集所說的，他令人欽佩，他能鼓舞人心，但其中也帶有一絲喜劇色彩和災難陰影，總是籠罩在納爾遜身上，特別是當他踏上陸地時，湯姆。不幸的是，在本集的後半部分，他將要做的就是這件事，並且會帶來災難性的後果。好了。因此，任何收聽的愛国英国听众，你们已经在前半部分大饱眼福了，但恐怕后半部分，就没那么辉煌了。这个冬天，搭乘波特航空前往坦帕旅行。
and for him, it should be a moment of transcendent happiness, a moment of complete apotheosis, but there is a sting in the tail, isn't there? There always is with Nelson because, as we said in the first episode, he's admirable, he's inspirational, but there's also a slight element of comedy and disaster that always sort of hanging over Nelson, especially Tom, when he goes onto land. And unfortunately, in the second half of this episode, that is what he is going to do with disastrous consequences. Okay. So any patriotic Britons listening, you've sucked your full with the first half, but I'm afraid the second half, it's slightly less glorious. This winter, take a trip to Tampa on Porter Airlines.
在旅途中享受坦帕湾温暖的气候和波特航空热情周到的服务。所有波特航空的机票都包含啤酒、葡萄酒和零食，飞机上还提供免费的高速流媒体Wi-Fi，且没有中间座位。您的坦帕湾度假之旅将包含美好的时光、放松身心以及绝佳的墨西哥湾沿岸天气。访问 flyporter.com，真正享受经济舱的乐趣。一个场地传奇诞生了。麦当劳的猛龙香辣鸡肉干酪肉汁薯条。我们世界闻名的薯条上铺满了香辣鸡肉、肉汁、拉丝干酪块、玉米饼条，并淋上了纳乔干酪酱。快来尝鲜吧。
Enjoy the warm Tampa Bay temperatures and warm Porter hospitality on your way there. All Porter Fairs include beer, wine and snacks and free fast-streaming Wi-Fi on planes with no middle seats. And your Tampa Bay vacation includes good times, relaxation, and great Gulf Coast weather. Visit flyporter.com and actually enjoy economy. A courtside legend is born. The Raptor Chicken Nacho Poutine from McDonald's. Our world famous fries topped with seasoned chicken, gravy, stringy cheese curds, tortilla strips, and drizzled with nacho cheese sauce. Get your claws on it.
仅限限时供应，安大略省参与活动的麦当劳餐厅均有售。在安特卫普，我们知道您时刻在移动。修复这个，搞定那个。您到达一个目的地，然后又前往下一个。当生活以某种速度运转时——嗯，就是生活本身，安特卫普就在您身边，无论是在转角还是在全球各地。我们将助您不断前行。安特卫普。让生活随心而动。你好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。纳尔逊和现在已经成为圣文森特伯爵的约翰·杰维斯，他们赢得了圣文森特角战役。英国免于潜在的入侵，所以太棒了。纳尔逊绝对是个英雄。但多米尼克，我们在前半部分结束时谈到，这一半将
For a limited time only, at participating McDonald's restaurants in Ontario. At Enterprise, we know you're constantly on the move. Getting this, fixing that. You reach a destination, and then it's on to the next. And when life is moving at the speed of, well, life, Enterprise is right there with you, around the corner and around the globe. We'll keep you moving forward. Enterprise. Her lives in drive. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. Nelson and the Earl of St. Vincent, as he now is, John Jervis, they have won the Battle of St. Vincent. Britain has been saved from potential invasion, so hurrah. Nelson's an absolute hero. But Dominic, we were talking at the end of the first half how this half is going to be
稍微没那么辉煌，对吧？确实如此。所以他们赢得了战斗，但纳尔逊就是纳尔逊，总有一个扫兴的尾声。当他踏上陆地时总是这样。所以荣耀之后便是在陆地上发生的不幸插曲。基本上他们前往里斯本进行休整和维修。当他们在那里时，他们听到报告或谣言
slightly less glorious, isn't it? It is indeed. So they have won the battle, but Nelson being Nelson, there's always a little deflating epilogue. There is when he goes on land. So glory followed by an unfortunate episode on terra firma. So basically they go to Lisbon to rest and repair. And while they're there, they hear reports or rumors
说墨西哥总督将要航行回国或将他的珍宝船队送回国。所以这些来自古巴和阿根廷的白银。所有这一切都带有非常伊丽莎白女王时代的特质，不是吗？你能想象德雷克。是的，完全如此。起初，现已成为圣文森特伯爵的约翰·杰维斯爵士说，如果我们四处闲逛并封锁加的斯，我们应该能抓到这支船队。但在加的斯外面晃悠，毫无收获。纳尔逊和特鲁布里奇，他的老搭档，两人的头脑都有点热。他们凑在一起商量说，听着，我们认为这支船队一定去了特内里费。
that the viceroy of Mexico is going to be sailing home or sending home his treasure fleet. So this is the silver from Cuba and from the Argentine. And it's very kind of Elizabethan quality to all this, isn't it? You can imagine Drake. Yeah, absolutely. And at first the new Earl of St. Vincent as he is, Sir John Gervais, says, well, if we hang around and blockade Cadiz, we should be able to get this fleet. But hang around outside Cadiz, no joy at all. And Nelson and Troubridge, his old pal, they're both kind of hot headed. And they put their heads together and they say, look, we think this fleet must have made for Tenerife.
他们去了那里。所以在非洲海岸外的加那利群岛，西班牙的岛屿。这就是为什么我们一直没见到它。他们把珍宝船队停泊在那里。我们可以占领特内里费。我们可以拿到这些宝藏。这些宝藏，数量惊人的白银。这能让他们一辈子衣食无忧，对吧？
That's where they've gone. So down in the Canary Islands, off the coast of Africa, Spanish islands. That's why we haven't seen it. They've anchored the treasure fleet there. We can take Tenerife. We can get this treasure. This treasure, this enormous quantity of silver. It would make them for life, wouldn't it?
确实如此。而且这可能会改变战争的进程，将西班牙打出局。谁知道呢？这太棒了。当然有那种因素，因为这全关乎爱国主义。但也有另一个因素，那就是这两个人都会变得富可敌国。他们会的。而在此时，他们两个人都还不是。
It would. And it could change the fortunes of the war, could knock Spain out of the war. Who knows? This is amazing. Well, there is that of course, because of course it's all about patriotism. But there is also the element that both men would be unbelievably rich. They would be. And at this point then, neither of them are.
是的，因为纳尔逊，事实上，在他的大半个职业生涯中——没有拿到多少战利品。从来没有真正拿到过多少战利品。他一直得到的都是些微不足道的私掠船和小玩意儿。他一门心思为了服役和他的职业生涯。他没有拿到多少战利品。从来没有真正拿到过多少战利品。他一直得到的都是些微不足道的私掠船和小玩意儿。他全是为了，你知道的，为国家效力。我觉得公平地说，他也想要点钱。他确实想要。所以纳尔逊对圣文森特说，听着，我只需要大约八艘船。拜托，我们能做到。圣文森特说，好吧，去吧。他们在七月出发了。他们有三艘像样的船，也就是所谓的74门炮舰，包括纳尔逊的新船“忒修斯”号，以及一些护卫舰和炮艇等等。
No, because Nelson, in fact, through much of his career- Hasn't taken many prizes. Never really takes many prizes. They're always piffling little privateers and things that he's been getting. He's all about serving his career. He hasn't taken many prizes. Never really takes many prizes. They're always piffling little privateers and things that he's been getting. He's all about, you know, serving his country. He fancies a bit of money as well, I think it's fair to say. He does. So Nelson says to St Vincent, look, I just need eight ships or so. Come on, we can do this. St Vincent says, all right, fine, go for it. And they set off in July. They've got three sort of decent sized ships, 74 as they're called, including Nelson's new ship, the Theseus and some frigates and artillery boats and all
计划是纳尔逊指挥船只，特鲁布里奇率领地面部队。会有什么问题呢？六天后，他们抵达了特内里费。我想甚至在这个时候，他们向外望去，心里想：这比我们预期的要困难，因为这里有非常陡峭的黑色海滩和高耸的悬崖。天气热得难以置信，这是他们没有真正预料到的。而且这里防守非常严密，不是吗？防守非常严密。岸边到处都是火炮。这是一个充满威胁的地方。正如纳尔逊职业生涯中并不罕见的情况一样，他们到达时，对等待他们的是什么并没有真正的概念，也没有地图之类的东西，没有圣克鲁斯-德特内里费的计划等等。
this. The plan is Nelson will command the ships, Troubridge will lead the men on land. What could possibly go wrong? Six days later, they pitch up in Tenerife. And I think even at this point, they look out and they're like, it's kind of harder than we're expecting because it's kind of these very steep black beaches and high cliffs. It's incredibly hot and this is something they haven't really bargained for. And it's very well defended as well isn't it? Very well defended. So there are kind of gums all along the shore. It's a menacing place. They have arrived, as is not untypical, in Nelson's career with no real sense of what will await them and no maps or anything like that, no plans of Santa Cruz de Tenerife and all this.
这个计划是纳尔逊指挥舰艇，特劳桥率领陆上人员。能出什么差错呢？六天后，他们抵达了特内里费岛。我想即使在这个时候，他们向外望去也会觉得，这比我们预期的要难，因为这里有非常陡峭的黑色沙滩和高耸的悬崖。天气热得难以置信，这是他们没有料到的。而且这里的防御也非常坚固，对吧？防御非常坚固。海岸沿线到处都是火炮。这是一个充满威胁的地方。正如纳尔逊职业生涯中屡见不鲜的那样，他们到达时完全不知道等待他们的是什么，没有地图或类似的东西，没有圣克鲁斯-德特内里费的计划，诸如此类。
Anyway they arrive and they say well come on, we're the British, we can't possibly lose. They make a first attack before dawn on the 22nd July and I think it's fair to describe this attack as a total and utter shambles. The current is so strong it takes them ages to get to the beach, they don't get to the beach until dawn has broken so everyone can see them. They start ringing the church bells and firing cannons. Trubridge goes ahead anyway, leads his men up this beach.
无论如何，他们到达后说：‘来吧，我们是英国人，我们绝不可能失败。’他们在7月22日破晓前发起了第一次进攻，我认为用‘完全且彻底的混乱’来形容这次进攻并不过分。水流太急了，他们花了很长时间才到达海滩，直到天亮才登岸，所以所有人都看得见他们。他们开始敲响教堂钟声并鸣放礼炮。特鲁布里奇还是向前推进，率领手下登上这片海滩。
They go up this mountain dragging two cannons with them. It's so hot. It takes them ages to get up to the top of this mountain. When the time they get there, they're in an absolutely terrible state. Trubridge's men are worried that Trubridge is going to drop dead because he's sweating so much, kind of panting like a beast. Still got his uniform on. Exactly. They get up there with the guns. They realize the range isn't long enough to reach the town. So it's been a complete and utter waste of time. They come back down again, very hot still.
他们拖着两门大炮爬上这座山。天气太热了。他们花了很长时间才爬上山顶。等他们到那儿时，状态已经糟透了。特鲁布里奇的手下担心他会一命呜呼，因为他汗如雨下，像野兽一样喘着粗气。还穿着军服。确实。他们带着大炮上去了。他们发现射程不够，够不到镇子。所以这完全是白忙一场。他们又退了回来，身上还是滚烫的。
Two of them fall down the mountain and die. They've been completely humiliated. Now, at this point, Nelson should have given up. He knows himself, he says victory is a forlorn hope, but he says the honor of our country demands a second attempt, which is frankly madness, absolute madness. It's very Churchillian, Churchill Gallipoli or something, isn't it? Kind of just doubling down on a very bad plan. So now he thinks, well, we'll attack Tenerife, we'll just go straight for it. We'll just, what could go wrong? We'll just go straight up the beach, blast our way in, get the treasure, storm the Citadel. Brilliant. He probably, I think, expects to die on this.
其中两人从山上摔下来死了。他们受到了彻底的羞辱。现在，到了这个地步，纳尔逊本该放弃的。他自己也知道，他说胜利是一线希望渺茫，但他却说祖国的荣誉需要我们进行第二次尝试，这坦白说简直是疯狂，绝对的疯狂。这非常像丘吉尔的风格，加里波利或什么的，对吧？有点像在一个极糟的计划上继续加码。所以现在他想，好吧，我们要进攻特内里费，直接冲过去。我们直奔主题，有什么好怕的？我们直接冲上海滩，杀进去，夺取宝藏，攻占城堡。太棒了。我想他大概已经做好了死在那儿的准备。
Well, because he is leading from the front, isn't he? And I guess this is why his men are happy to follow him on what they must have reckoned. I can't say no. If he's going, he can't say no, can he? Because it's not just that he's facing risks that are as great as he's asking them to face, but they're actually greater. As ever, he will be in his full uniform, he'll have his medals, and he'll be at the front of the expedition. And I think a sign that he thinks that this might not end well is he burns his letters from Fanny in his cabin that night, the night before they go. And Josiah comes in to help him do it. So
嗯，因为他是身先士卒的，对吧？我想这也是为什么他的手下乐意跟着他去冒他们肯定觉得……我没法拒绝。如果他要上，他就不能拒绝，对吧？因为不仅是他面临的风险和他要求他们面对的一样大，实际上还要大得多。一如既往，他穿着全套军服，戴着勋章，冲在远征队伍的最前面。我认为这可能不会有好结果的一个迹象是，那天晚上，也就是出发前的那天晚上，他在船舱里烧掉了范妮写给他的信。何西亚进来帮他做这件事。所以
Josiah, of course, has been hanging around all this time. So he's 17 by now. 17. He's huge, but he's still quite useless. Well, you say that, but I think, you know, as we will see, he proves his worth. He does one good thing, Tom. It's fair to say. Nelson says to Josiah, look, when I've gone, you take care of the ship. And Josiah says the ship must take care of herself. And Nelson, supposing your poor mother was to lose us both, what will she do? And Josiah says to him, I will go with you this night if I never go again.
当然，何西亚这一路都在闲逛。所以他现在17岁了。17岁。他长得很大只，但还是没什么用。话虽如此，但我认为，正如我们所见，他证明了自己的价值。他做了一件好事，汤姆。这么说挺公道的。纳尔逊对何西亚说：‘听着，我走后，你照顾好这艘船。’何西亚却说：‘这艘船必须自己照顾自己。’纳尔逊说：‘假设你可怜的母亲失去了我们两个，她该怎么办？’何西亚对他说：‘今晚我跟你走，哪怕以后再也不走了。’
You know, that's not useless. No, that's admirable, I guess. It's brave and plucky. As we will see, it's just as well that he does. They set off late at night, they're rowing through the darkness. They approach this beach and then they hear Spanish voices. They are discovered Tom. The bells are ringing, there's lanterns blazing, there's people firing guns and stuff and Nelson thinks, oh no, nightmare.
你知道，这并非毫无用处。不，我想这是令人钦佩的。勇敢而有骨气。正如我们将看到的，他这么做正是时候。他们在深夜出发，划船穿过黑暗。他们靠近这片海滩，然后听到了西班牙人的声音。他们被发现了，汤姆。钟声敲响，灯火辉煌，有人在开枪等等，纳尔逊心想：‘噢，不，噩梦降临了。’
People are falling into the sea, they're in danger of being caught in this crossfire, basically helpless. And Nelson, very Nelsonian behaviour, he stands up, he draws his sword, he pushes through to the front of the boat, he's going to lead his men onto land up the beach, just go for it. And at that point he raises his sword, a shot hits him right in the right elbow. A few seconds he tries to stand up right, but then he staggers, he slumps, he falls down, Josiah is at his side. And this is where he proves his worth. The blood is pumping out, Josiah is appalled.
人们纷纷落入海中，面临着被这交叉火力击中的危险，基本上无能为力。而纳尔逊做出了非常“纳尔逊式”的举动：他站起身，拔出剑，挤到小艇最前方，准备带领手下登岸冲上海滩，直接干。就在这时，他举起剑，一发子弹正中他的右肘。几秒钟内他试图直立站着，但随后他踉跄了一下，瘫软下去，倒在地上，何西亚就在他身旁。这就是他证明自己价值的时刻。鲜血喷涌而出，何西亚惊呆了。
He could easily have lost it, but he doesn't. And he's got a neckerchief and he takes it off and he ties it around Nelson's arm to give Nelson a tourniquet. And this basically saves Nelson's life. So they get him into a boat and they row him back to the Theseus, to Nelson's ship. And the sailors see what's happened, see that his arm has gone. And so they lower a chair for him to sit on. But this is, Nelson isn't going to sit in a chair. Way too undignified. And so he reaches for a rope with his one good arm.
他本可能会惊慌失措，但他没有。他有一条围巾，他把它解下来，系在纳尔逊的手臂上作为止血带。这基本上救了纳尔逊的命。于是他们把他扶上小艇，划回“忒修斯号”，也就是纳尔逊的旗舰。水手们看到发生了什么，看到他的胳膊没了。于是他们放下椅子让他坐下。但是，纳尔逊才不会坐椅子呢。太不得体了。于是他用那只好手去抓一根绳子。
And it's so Nelsonian. He then hauls himself up using his one arm. Incredible. With the blood presumably still seeping out through Josiah's neck, a chief, no matter how tight he's tied it. And he gets on the ship and he salutes using his left hand. He does. And he says to his men, tell the surgeon to get his instruments ready for, I know
这太有纳尔逊的风格了。然后他单臂将自己拉了上去。太不可思议了。血大概还在透过何西亚的围巾往外渗，不管他系得有多紧。他登上了船，用左手敬礼。他真的这么做了。他对部下说：‘让外科医生准备好器械，因为我知道……
I must lose my arm and the sooner it is off the better. Because of course he's right in this period, you're hitting the arm or a leg. The best thing to do is to get that off straight away and reduce the chance of infection or serious complications. So it's helped down to the cockpit to be in the cockpit at this point is to be in a scene from hell, probably blood everywhere. They've sanded the floor. The surgeon has got his the floor. The surgeon has got his saws ready. The surgeon is called Eshel B.
我必须截肢，越早越好。当然，在那个时代他是对的，当你手臂或腿部受伤时。最好的做法是立刻截掉，以减少感染或严重并发症的机会。于是他被扶到中舱，在这个时候的中舱就像人间炼狱，到处都是血。他们在地板上撒了沙子。外科医生的……地板上撒了沙子。外科医生准备好了锯子。这位外科医生叫埃舍尔比。
Not Stephen Maturin. No, not Stephen Maturin. Now he can see straight away that Nelson's arm has been shattered above the elbow and that one of the arteries has been ruptured and unless he can intervene, Nelson will die. They set up some sea chests as a makeshift table. Their surgeon's assistants put Nelson on his back. Then they tie a strap above his elbow. They use a screw to tighten the strap. And then the men hold Nelson down. First of all, what Eshelby does, he slices open Nelson's arm and he gets forceps to pull
不是斯蒂芬·马图林。不，不是斯蒂芬·马图林。现在他一眼就能看出纳尔逊的胳膊在肘部上方已经被炸碎了，其中一条动脉已经破裂，除非他采取干预措施，否则纳尔逊会死。他们把几个海军箱子拼成一张临时手术台。外科医生的助手把纳尔逊仰面放好。然后他们在他的肘部上方绑上一条带子。他们用螺丝把带子绞紧。接着几个人把纳尔逊按住。首先，埃舍尔比切开纳尔逊的手臂，用镊子拉出……
out the arteries. And he's got thread, hasn't he? He's got a silken thread and he ties all the ends of the arteries up. With thread. Yeah. And with the expectation that if the wound heals, the thread will just drop off. Exactly. But actually, as we will see, that takes a bit of a time. And then he reaches, this is the point where if you're Nelson, you're thinking, could life get any worse? It can. Because at this point, Escherby reaches for his handsaw
拉出动脉。他有线，对吧？他有一根丝线，把所有的动脉断端都扎起来。用线。是的。期望伤口愈合后，线会自动脱落。没错。但实际上，正如我们将看到的，这需要一段时间。然后他伸手，如果你是纳尔逊，你觉得生活还能更糟吗？能。因为就在这时，埃舍尔比拿起了他的手锯……
and begins to saw at Nelson's arm. And the thing that Nelson remembers is that it's cold. That's right. Yes. The steel is cold and you know he recovers from the operation, but from that point on he orders that surgeons knives and saws should always be heated before any operation. Yeah. The one thing he takes from it. So to cut a long story short, the expedition has been a complete and utter disaster. Troubridge's men did get ashore. They ended up being trapped, I think in a nunnery or something like that. The Spanish behave absolutely tremendously. They surrender to the Spanish and the Spanish say, well, you can go back to your ship. You know, you've had a crack, but that's fair enough. We all, you know, it's war.'s war. These things happen in love and war while you're waiting for your ship. They say, are you hungry? It's like some tapas. They bring them bread and cheese and
开始锯纳尔逊的胳膊。纳尔逊记住的事情是那把锯子很冷。没错。是的。钢是冷的，你知道他从手术中恢复了过来，但从那时起他下令，任何手术前外科医生的刀和锯子都必须加热。是的。这是他从中汲取的唯一教训。所以长话短说，这次远征是一场彻底的灾难。特鲁布里奇的手下确实上了岸。他们最后被困在了一座修女院或类似的地方。西班牙人的表现简直棒极了。他们向西班牙人投降，西班牙人说：‘好吧，你们可以回你们的船上去了。你知道，你们尝试过了，但这也算合情合理。我们都，你知道，这是战争。战争就是这样。在等船的时候，这些在情场和战场上的事难免发生。’他们问：‘你们饿了吗？来点小吃怎么样？’他们拿来了面包、奶酪和……
wine. They say, if you got injured men, we'll treat them in the hospital. They're commander. So we should say a word for the Spanish commander on Tenerife, who's Don Antonio Gutierrez. And as the British sailors put it, he showed that the old Spanish honor still flourished on the island of Tenerife. So, Fever of Spania. Fever of Spania, exactly. Well done, Spain. The British had lost 150 men and gained absolutely nothing.
葡萄酒。他们说：‘如果你们有伤员，我们在医院里为他们治疗。’他们的指挥官——所以我们应该提一下特内里费的西班牙指挥官，他叫唐·安东尼奥·古铁雷斯。正如英国水手所说，他展现了古老的西班牙荣誉仍在特内里费岛上熠熠生辉。所以，西班牙万岁。西班牙万岁，干得好，西班牙。英国人损失了150人，却什么也没得到。
But I mean, it's still not as bad as the Mosquito Coast. No, I guess not. So, you know, there's that to bear in mind. Nelson has lost his right arm from just above the elbow and he's being dosed for laudanum, but he is in excruciating pain because one of these silk threads binding the arteries has got stuck in some obscure way and basically has not dropped off. No, and it won't drop off for months and months, will it? Exactly.
不过，这依然没有蚊子海岸那么糟糕。不，我想也是。所以，这一点还是得记在心里。纳尔逊失去了肘部以上的右臂，并被大剂量注射了鸦片酊，但他却承受着剧烈的痛苦，因为扎动脉的其中一根丝线以某种奇特的方式卡住了，根本没有脱落。对，而且接下来的好几个月都不会脱落，对吧？确实如此。
And it's constant agony as a result. His wound is still open and it's incredibly sore. So back they go and they're sailing back and he writes to St Vincent. This is the first letter that we have from Nelson using his left hand. You can see it if you Google it online. Abysmally written obviously because he's not using his wrong hand, but it's full of self-pity. Dominic. What? You can't accuse Britain's greatest hero of self-pity. Yeah, but Tom, come on. No, it's not self-pity. He doesn't say these things happen.
结果就是无休止的痛苦。他的伤口仍然没有闭合，疼得厉害。于是他们启航回国，他在航行中给圣文森特写信。这是我们能看到的纳尔逊用左手写的的第一封信。如果你在网上谷歌一下就能看到。字迹显然糟透了，因为他用的不是惯用手，但信中充满了自怨自艾。多米尼克。什么？你不能指责英国最伟大的英雄自怨自艾。行了，汤姆，拜托。不，这不是自怨自艾。他并不是说这些事情发生了……
He's full of regret that he can no longer serve his country. He says, the sooner I get to a very humble cottage, the better. I should make room for a better man to serve the state. I am become a burden to my friends and useless to my country. When I leave your command, I shall become dead to the world. All of this kind of thing. That's not self-pity. This is, Tom, this is self-pity.
他充满了遗憾，因为他无法再为国家效力。他说：‘我越早到一个简陋的小屋越好。我应该腾出位置让更好的人来为国家效力。我已经成了朋友们的累赘，对国家毫无用处。当我离开你的指挥时，我将对这个世界死去。’诸如此类的话。这不是自怨自艾。汤姆，这就是自怨自艾。
No, it's regret that he thinks, serve his country as he would like to. And I think that reflects very well on his patriotism. St Vincent, who could have been very cross with Nelson, said, the stupid scheme of yours has gone horribly wrong and has cost the lives of 150 people. He actually writes to him and says, don't worry about it. Mere mortals cannot command success. Well, he says to Nelson that he would be proud to bow to Nelson's stump. Yeah.
不，这是遗憾，他认为自己无法像以前那样为国效力。我认为这很好地反映了他的爱国主义精神。圣文森特本可以对纳尔逊非常生气，他说：‘你这个愚蠢的计划大错特错，还害死了150人的生命。’但他实际上写信给他说：‘别担心。凡人无法保证每次都成功。’好吧，他对纳尔逊说，他会为向纳尔逊的断臂鞠躬而感到骄傲。是的。
I think reflects very well on, well, St Vincent as he is now, isn't he? It does. So effectively what he says to Nelson is, listen, don't worry, your career is not yet over. And of course it isn't because next week we will turn to what for me is possibly the most thrilling chapter in Nelson's life. One of the most glorious episodes, Tom, in British naval history. The hunt for Bonaparte and the battle of the Nile.
我认为这很好地反映了……圣文森特现在的态度，对吧？确实如此。所以他实际上对纳尔逊说的是：‘听着，别担心，你的职业生涯还没结束。’当然没有，因为下周我们将转向对纳尔逊来说可能是最激动人心的篇章。英国海军史上最辉煌的篇章之一。搜寻波拿巴与尼罗河战役。
So members of the Rest is History Club, you can hear it right now. The rest of you, if you would like to join Nelson sailing to and fro across the Mediterranean and the hunt for Napoleon, you can sign up at therestishistory.com. But either way, we will be with you very soon. Toodle pip. Bye bye. Now, Tom, we have something unbelievably exciting to share with our listeners, don't we? Absolutely we do, Dominic. It's that time of year again when you've got to find that
所以“历史的休止符”俱乐部成员们，你们现在就可以收听了。至于其他人，如果你想加入纳尔逊在地中海航行、搜寻拿破仑的旅程，可以在 therestishistory.com 注册。无论如何，我们很快就会与大家见面。再见。拜拜。现在，汤姆，我们有一件难以置信的令人兴奋的事情要和听众分享，对吧？我们当然有，多米尼克。又到了每年的这个时候，你得为生命中的挚爱寻找那份……
perfect gift for the loved one in your life. And we are thrilled to help you with that challenge. We are announcing the launch of the Rest Is History merchandise. Yes, you can now own a piece of history literally. We've literally got shirts, mugs, phone cases, notebooks, so much just in time for Christmas. Unbelievable scenes Tom because these aren't just any shirts and mugs. Tom these are exclusive Rest is History designs and they have been designed specifically to outdo the Rory and Alastair t-shirts that our friends on the Rest is Politics team have been flocking on their tour of England that they've done. That's right Dominic, history will always trump politics. And our new merch truly is the perfect gift for any history fan, whether they're a friend
完美的礼物。我们非常高兴能帮您应对这个挑战。我们宣布推出“历史的休止符”官方周边商品。是的，你现在可以真正地拥有一段历史了。我们真的推出了T恤、马克杯、手机壳、笔记本，种类繁多，正好赶上圣诞节。难以置信的场景，汤姆，因为这些不只是普通的T恤和马克杯。汤姆，这些是“历史的休止符”独家设计，它们的设计专门为了胜过我们“政治的休止符”团队的朋友们在英国巡演时抢购的罗里和阿拉斯泰尔T恤。没错，多米尼克，历史永远胜过政治。我们的新周边绝对是任何历史迷的完美礼物，无论他们是节目的……
of the show or dare we say someone who's not yet a friend of the show. Yeah, I mean this is an unbelievably cunning wheeze isn't it? Really is. Because if you're a loyal friend of the show, you can wear a t-shirt that proudly declares your allegiance. And if you still need convincing, you know who you are, then you can buy a not a friend of the show version as well. So you can make your point with a t-shirt or a hoodie. It is the perfect icebreaker at parties. What's this you say? You don't know the rest is history.
朋友，还是我们敢说，甚至还不是节目的朋友。是的，我的意思是，这是一个难以置信的精明把戏，对吧？确实如此。因为如果你是节目的忠实朋友，你可以穿上一件自豪地宣称你忠诚的T恤。如果你还需要被说服——你知道你是谁，那么你也可以买一件“还不是节目的朋友”版本。所以你可以通过一件T恤或连帽衫表明你的立场。它是派对上绝佳的破冰话题。你说什么？你不知道“历史的休止符”吗？
Well let me tell you and you will have the perfect shirt while you talk to people about General Gordon or pigeons or the Kaiser or whatever it might be. So the possibilities are endless. And Dominic there's lots more. There are sacral mugs. So that's brilliant. And maybe you're an Athelstan. You are catered for as well.
那让我来告诉你，当你在和别人谈论戈登将军、信鸽、德皇或诸如此类的事情时，你将拥有一件完美的衬衫。所以可能性是无限的。多米尼克，还有很多其他东西。有萨克逊马克杯。这太棒了。也许你是个埃塞尔斯坦迷。你也会得到满足的。
Lots of Athelstan stuff. So truly it's beyond a dream gift, isn't it? People Tom have never had it so good. And in fact, if you're a club member, there is a special discount code that will come in the newsletter for members. And if you order before the 1st of December, then you'll get this amazing discount
有很多关于埃塞尔斯坦的周边。所以这真的是一份超越梦想的礼物，对吧？汤姆，人们从未过上过这么好的日子。事实上，如果你是俱乐部会员，时事通讯中会包含一个专享折扣码。如果你在12月1日之前下单，你就会得到这个惊人的折扣……
and everything will be brilliant. So basically, this is gonna be the best Christmas ever. So what you need to do is head over to www.goalhanger.shop, grab your Restors History gear and make sure you order before the 1st of December, if you're a club member to get that discount. Yeah. If you're not out to your friends, especially people who listen to other Goalhanger podcasts, like the Restors Politics, this is absolutely the way to
一切都会变得完美。所以基本上，这将是有史以来最棒的圣诞节。你需要做的是前往 www.goalhanger.shop，抢购你的“历史的休止符”装备，并确保在12月1日之前下单（如果你是俱乐部会员的话），以获得该折扣。是的。如果你还没有向你的朋友们“出柜”，特别是那些收听其他 Goalhanger 播客（比如“政治的休止符”）的人，这绝对是……
do it. So remember to head to www.goalhanger.shop to get your merch. And remember club members order before the 1st of December to take advantage of that exclusive discount. And we'll be sharing on social media our favourite pictures of you in your restless history merch. So send these in over Christmas morning. And remember that is www.goalhanger.shop. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
做这件事的方法。所以请记住前往 www.goalhanger.shop 获取你的周边商品。请记住俱乐部会员要在12月1日之前下单，以利用那个独家折扣。我们将在社交媒体上分享你们穿着“历史的休止符”周边的最喜爱照片。所以请在圣诞节早晨把这些照片发过来。请记住网址是 www.goalhanger.shop。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。